Let's assume that we have a single
autonomous system with static link weights as shown.
In such a setup, routers will flood
information to one another to learn the network
topology, including the link weights on, links
connecting individual routers. An operator can affect how
traffic flows through the network. By configuring the
link weights. By changing the link weight configuration,
an operator can affect the shortest path between
two points in this graph. Thus, affecting the
way that traffic flows. In the link weight
settings shown here, traffic would flow along the green
path. Suppose that the operator would like to
shift traffic off of a congested link in the
middle of the network. Such as this one.
By changing the link weight from one to three.
The shortest path between this node and this node,
now takes an alternate route. So we can see
from this simple example, That, by adjusting the link
weights in a intra-domain topology, the operator can affect
how traffic flows between different points in the network,
thus affecting the load on the network links. In
practice, network operators set these link weights in a
variety of ways. One could set the link weights
inversely proportional to capacity. Proportional to propagation delay, or the
operator might perform some network wide optimization, based on traffic.